[Music]
hi I'm Lisa James here with games wats
own Mark Walton who has recently been to
see Assassin's Creed chronicles China
now mark yes and I said it wasn't the
only game you saw that day oh that's
right China is not the only country that
they're going to be chronicling as such
so there's gonna be a tassel squeak
chronicles China Assassin's Creed
chronicles India and the Assassin's
Creed chronicles Russia each of which
will feature different Assassin's based
on like the larger Assassin's Creed
universe I don't know like how into like
the side films or the books or like
anything you know you read the Animus
stuff you got to read the Animus stuff
you got to watch the short film like the
China one is based off what was the
short film called I've got written down
here it is called AC embers Assassin's
Creed embers so you can go watch that I
believe it was given away as part of the
Status Creed Revelations and this the
story of Assassin's Creed China follows
directly on with it that okay so I mean
what does the gameplay like is it gonna
be like the big 3d open worlds that were
used to
or is it back to the real roots isn't
the roots of Assassin's Creed so
basically what they're doing is they're
going hey you guys remember those cool
2d Prince of Persia games everyone likes
oh yeah i toast remember those they're
just doing that like here we go his
principle is that we're gonna slap
assassin's creed skin on it and sell it
to you lovely people for lots of money
it's actually quite cool though like
it's you know I think one of the best
things about it is the art style like so
in Assassin's Creed China it's very much
like they've got this sort of
monochromatic sort of art style with
lots of little reds and stuff sprinkled
around just like give it like a bit of a
dark feel it's very cool and you know
it's all like hand-painted and stuff
like that so you know it's nice quite
neat so in terms of gameplay itself is
it gonna be more like the action heavy
Assassin's Creed or is it more focused
on self it's so you can if you want to
go around like current people and face
for the sword
you can they've made it difficult so the
idea with the combat is you have very
similar to status creative block move
but because it's on the 2d plane
essentially the guy comes towards you
block the move BAM hit him back right
but they don't want you to do that as
much as possible the idea is is that you
use the environment so like have stealth
basically so you get bonuses
if you can complete a small section of
the game like without hurting anyone
you get like a stealth bonus and in
order to facilitate south on a 2d plane
you get like these cool like looking
cones of vision cones
yeah like old-school Metal Gear Solid
sort of stuff right and so when you walk
past them these cones sort of you use
that to plan how you're going to attack
the area so like as the guards walk past
each other you'll see where the cones go
and you're like okay I know that I can
go this way or I can go that way at that
certain time and then you've got eagle
vision as well which shows you where the
guards walk back and forth so you sort
of planning all around there and then
doing your sweet stealth kills or
whatever and because it's on like this
2d plane it's kind of different to
Assassin's Creed yeah think about it a
little bit differently how you plan
those attacks but you can still sort of
hang off the edge sort of the fun
playing edge and then drag people down
and there's like little hidey holes
where you can put dead bodies and stuff
because if if someone finds a dead body
and you're in one of these like big
areas where there's like it's like a
separate door and if you alert one of
the guards loads of them come rushing
out and then you find this group you
have to run away so you have a pretty
meaty chunk of hands-on time what was
your favorite kind of moment so
interestingly like I quite liked the
slower self stuff but on the last level
of China : cause it's different they're
like okay forget about stealth you guys
you have to just run from one end of the
level to the other as quickly as
possible
and in that level is when basically
you're on these boats and the whole
thing's burning down and it's just
really cool it's just like you have to
just do it like so quickly and there's
this cool move that you can do which to
the ages to get right it's kind of
tricky to do but you sort of slide
underneath like guards and at the same
time attack them and you basically just
slice their crotch off like you slide
underneath and he holds his sword up we
just go wham yeah the old sliding crush
exactly so so you know it's quite neat
and I like the fast pace a bit of that
but it's I guess it's the balance right
it's the balance between those slower
portions and those faster portions that
made it really cool and when's it out so
the game is gonna be April 21st in the
US I believe in April 22nd in the UK
awesome so for more on Assassin's Creed
chronicles China India and Russia
there's three that make sure you keep
tuned to u games
[Music]
you
[Music]